the fan base that you have is so intense
does it ever get to the point where it
feels weird or bored elusive borderline
strange invasive yes yeah I mean there
are there moments I am she was probably
I think after catching fire came out I
was home for Christmas and and where is
home Kentucky Kentucky yeah and I was
back there and it was like they after
Chris was having dinner with my
grandparents and there's a ring of the
doorbell and I go to the front door and
it's like two like young probably 12 13
year old girls with their mom and
they're wearing like foo like my face
was all over their clothing and they're
like cellphones have my face on the back
and I was like looking at like a bunch
of weird mirrors pointing at myself and
straight it's like two thirteen-year-old
girls whatever and their mom or mother
yeah and and where'd they come from
Chicago they driven down like six hours
yeah they drove you oh yeah she's here
yeah no he's here but yeah they
literally drove down thing like he might
be home for Christmas let's see we could
get him and they they were right I was
and it was like a weird moment where I
didn't know how to react because I felt
bad that they driven all this way to
just meet me which is like whatever and
then like they were crying and I didn't
know like if it was my fault I didn't
know how so I guess was your fault it
was completely my fault also what's the
MA the mom drove them yeah it was
actually recently I was shooting in
Cincinnati again and and we're filming
kind of close to where I was from and I
was saying this hotel and and one more I
came out to my car to drive in to set
and there was like a mom and her two
kids again it's a good tip achill thing
that happens I guess and they were
sitting there by my car we're like
they're just waiting for me and I get
there and the mom starts crying and
she's like you don't know what we've
been going through I'm like I'm so sorry
the kids like moms look crying and then
and then the mom was like the kids are
showing reason and the mother's cries
but then and the mom is like I'm so
happy this is over I'm just like this
got really dark all of a sudden it's
it's over it's over now ya know what
that was I that is yeah that is very
dark hey thanks for watching be sure to
click subscribe to see even more great
Conan clips you may now return to your
pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography